[Music]
on this Saturday night the window to get
Canadians home is closing the Prime
Minister's plan to work with the
airlines we won't be able to reach
everyone is the next step restricting
travel within Canada the border closed
that kind of shut off a lifeline for all
of us
Global News reports on the impact in the
US and here at home New York's cases
spiked while millions of Americans are
forced into lockdown what
Italy's kovat 19 death toll rises as
other parts of Europe brace for the
worst
global national with Robin Gil
good evening and thank you for joining
us tonight
we have the latest developments on the
Cova 19 crisis the Northwest Territories
reported its first case now parts of
Canada are looking at restricting their
borders inside the country like the
Northwest Territories which is
prohibiting most travel into that part
of the country today the health minister
warned Canadians their efforts to stop
community transmission of the new
coronavirus will need to continue for
some time yet I understand that people
are frustrated and they're at home and
they're not doing things that they
normally do and they're not seeing their
loved ones but now is the time to double
down actually because one week is not
enough we will be in this situation for
a while and I think Canadians need to
understand this isn't about two weeks of
social distancing this is this is about
months of social distancing outside of
Canada hundreds of stranded Canadian
travelers are waiting to see if the
federal government will help repatriate
them the Prime Minister is working on a
plan to get Canadians abroad out but
more and more countries are shutting
down
so airspace and runways are diminishing
as David Aken reports the Prime Minister
admits not everyone will have a way home
as more and more countries around the
world closed their airspace or shut down
airports the federal government in
Canada is scrambling to do whatever it
can to repatriate Canadians abroad who
want to come home we're working with
Canadian airlines to make commercial
flights available for as many Canadians
who are stranded as possible we will
also be working with other countries to
ensure that our airlines have the
permissions and other supports necessary
to fly Air Canada for example landed a
plane Saturday afternoon in Morocco and
will take a plane load of Canadians from
that North African country to Montreal
on Sunday Trudeau also said the
government expects to secure flights
with returning Canadians from Peru
despite Peru's decision to ban all
flights in its airspace Canada is also
looking to get flights home from Spain
and other countries may follow but
Trudeau also had this warning now we
won't be able to reach everyone but
we're going to do our best
to help those we can the advice now for
Canadians abroad register with Global
Affairs Canada keep your smartphone
charged and be ready for a text email or
phone call and there was a special
message for retired Canadians who spend
their winters in the sunny south I would
like to say a word to our beloved
snowbirds
I want to remind them that they should
return to Canada as soon as possible
especially as flights become
increasingly scary and I want to
reassure them that the border will
always be open for them to return back
home in Canada meanwhile the first move
was made to restrict the travel of
Canadians within Canada the government
of the Northwest Territories
shortly before announcing its first
confirmed case said it would block all
non-essential travel into the territory
a move supported by Ottawa every
province and Regional Health Authority
has the same power to do the same thing
to shut off boarders or to put up
barriers at a city limit though the
federal Health Minister resisted the
idea of a broad-based inside the country
restriction it does not make sense from
my perspective as a health minister to
put an entire country on lockdown if in
fact we don't have the need to do so
from a science perspective in fact it
could create even more harm but even
though haidu argued against tighter
inter provincial or inter regional
travel restrictions Heidi was adamant on
this point time and again stay at home
please keep your social distance and be
prepared to do just that for weeks Robin
David Aken in Ottawa thinks David Global
News has learned the House of Commons
will reconvene Tuesday to deal with the
Cova 19 crisis but business will have to
be conducted with the minimum number of
MPs possibly only those who are within
driving distance of Ottawa there's an
acknowledgement that each party will try
to keep its MPs from flying the
government is not ruling out more
restrictions on travel if people refuse
to heed that call to stay home
the number of infected here in Canada is
rising quickly more than 1300 people
have tested positive for Kovan 19 19
people have now died there were big
jumps reported today in the worst-hit
says BC has the most now at 424 cases
and as David mentioned there is a first
confirmed case in Canada's far north
someone in Yellowknife tested positive
after travelling to BC and Alberta
Canadians woke up to a new reality today
the world's longest undefended border is
no longer open to most people as of
midnight the land border between Canada
and the u.s. closed to all non-essential
travel the move by the Canadian and
American governments is meant to help
curtail the spread of Cova 19-hour Jeff
simple was that
normally one of the country's busiest
crossings this morning Jeff a lot has
changed well Robin a Saturday during
March break in Niagara Falls would
normally be bustling with people and
traffic but take a look it is an
absolute ghost town here almost
completely deserted and this is a big
part of the reason why the canadian-us
border officially closed to all
non-essential traffic as of 12:01 this
morning but it seems not everyone got
the message minutes before midnight
Canadians arrived at the US border to
find the way already shut they don't
allowed me they said no sorry soon this
Toronto Area couple was hoping to visit
their children who live in the US but
we're told to turn back they said you
know you see the news everybody stay
home yes to him others also learned the
hard way that the border is now blocked
Bernie we're not using anymore this
Canadian was forced to walk back from
the US across a freezing bridge after
border guards wouldn't allow his wife to
drive over and pick him up the
government says the border is now closed
to tourists shoppers even asylum seekers
Canadians currently in the US are still
allowed to return home and cross-border
trade continues Albie it on a much
smaller scale
well the automotive industry is
basically shut down until the end of the
month that's our largest employer the
mayor of Windsor says 6,000 of his
residents work in the US many now
confused as to whether they'll be
allowed to cross for their commute I
think we're gonna have to test this a
little bit and just to figure out what
what is essential and not essential if
this Canadian couple works in the u.s.
she's a nurse and is still allowed south
of the border
but he works for a production company
and can no longer get a cross all over
the states we had set up for the next
six months and all that business is gone
the last time this border was closed was
after 9/11 and that closure only lasted
a couple of days the government says
this time the border will be closed for
at least one month after which they'll
reassess and decide whether to extend it
Robyn all right thanks for that Jeff
let's go to Jackson Frost Co who's
watching the border situation from the
American side tonight Jackson how is the
u.s. handling the Cova 19 crisis when it
comes to cross-border travel robbing the
US has adopted the same measures on both
its northern and southern borders
restricting all non-essential travel
like tourism or shopping but keeping the
doors open to trade and those who need
to work that has led some Canadian
snowbirds in Florida Arizona and
California scrambling to get home and
it's raising concerns about how daily
commerce will function in border cities
where people are used to moving back and
forth freely in cities along the
us-mexico border like El Paso Texas
thousands of people travel back and
forth to work or go shopping or even
access medical services and so the big
unanswered question remains what exactly
counts as essential travel the US has
said visa holders should still be able
to enter for essential jobs like
agriculture and medical workers it's not
clear if that applies to all categories
of visas and the US has actually
suspended issuing new visas at its
consulates and embassies worldwide all
of this is to say that travelers may
find the rules applied unevenly at
border crossings in the short term as US
border protection officials struggle to
one
stand and interpret these new rules
Robyn Jackson Prosecco in Washington
more than 80 million Americans are now
under orders to stay home several US
states are hoping to stop the spread of
Kovan 19 by cracking down on public
gatherings more than 24,000 Americans
have tested positive for the virus at
least 275 have died those numbers are
expected to rise substantially in the
coming days as Jennifer Johnson explains
hospitals in New York and Washington
state two of the hardest hit areas in
the US are already running out of
essential supplies as of Saturday
evening tens of millions of Americans
ordered to shelter at home as states
desperately try to stop the spread of
Kovan 19l annoy New Jersey joining New
York California Pennsylvania and
Connecticut in taking the drastic action
others are expected to follow every
American is a role to play in defending
our nation from this invisible horrible
enemy so we say stay at home and save
lives
president Trump has declared New York
with the highest number of cases a
federal disaster area over run hospitals
are already running at a protective
equipment
we are literally scouring the globe
looking for medical supplies we've
identified two million n95 masks which
are the high protection masks in
Washington State which has the highest
death toll in America health officials
say they will soon have to make
life-and-death decisions
rationing ventilators the notion that
this could happen in America where we
can see something coming and we can't
get the resources here to avert it is is
ridiculous it should not happen
all non-essential businesses in these
states will be closed but places like
gas stations and grocery stores will
remain open officers are cracking down
on those violating the orders we're
meeting with businesses where they don't
understand the verbal conversation we're
then going to serve them with a notice
for the first time in history the US
government has extended the federal tax
deadline for 90 days trying to ease the
financial burden on Americans over 2
million Americans are expected to file
for unemployment benefits by mid week as
more workers are laid off
the largest weekly increase in history
Congress and White House negotiators are
working through the weekend to hammer
out a 1 to 2 trillion dollar economic
aid package we're going to be floating
probably 70% of the nation's payroll
California's governor is requesting a
billion dollars for his state alone and
wants the u.s. naval hospital ship Mercy
to dock in Los Angeles
fearing over 20% of Californians will
need to be hospitalized desperate calls
for help as the u.s. faces a pandemic an
economic crisis like no other Jennifer
Johnson Global News Washington in Quebec
City police have made their first
coronavirus related arrest a woman who
tested positive for the disease was
arrested while being up for a walk in
her neighborhood it happened six days
after the province declared its 10-day
public health emergency
under this measure authorities are given
broad powers if someone jeopardizes the
health and safety of others the woman is
now in hospital and may face charges
we know you have lots of questions about
this virus our Jeff sample will continue
to consult with experts and try to
answer them email your questions at
global news dot CA and on our website
you'll find a special page dedicated
entirely to the new corona virus that's
a global news dossier / coronavirus
coming up italy imposes more
restrictions on public life as hundreds
more died and the tributes pour in for a
country music star Kenny Rogers
Australia's Bondi Beach has been shut
down temporarily officials were forced
to close the beach after thousands of
people flocked there in recent days
defying social distancing orders
lifeguards will now conduct regular
headcounts and they will shut down other
beaches if too many people gather in one
location Australia recently imposed
stricter socialising rules as part of
its code 19 response country has more
than a thousand confirmed cases of the
virus seven people have died sirens
blared across jordan's capitol today
marking the start of the country's
nationwide curfew
Jordan is limiting the movement of its
10 million citizens indefinitely to
combat the spread of Cova 19 anyone
caught violating the curfew can be
jailed for up to a year so far nearly
400 people have been arrested jordan has
85 confirmed cases of the virus Iran's
president held a cabinet meeting today
to discuss additional measures to fight
the spread of the new corona virus all
attendees except for president Hassan
rouhani wore facemasks Iran intz have
been encouraged to stay home for the
next two weeks and only leave if it is
absolutely necessary more than 20,000
people have tested positive for Cova 19
in that country more than 1500 people
have died the epicenter of the Cova 19
pandemic is still in Europe Italy is the
hardest hit country in the world 793
people died there in the past day alone
that pushes the death toll in Italy past
4,800 Spain now appears to be on a
similar trajectory and there are fears
France Germany and the United Kingdom
may not be far behind
Redmon Shannon reports
Italy's armed forces are having to work
harder every day transporting bodies out
of the worst-affected regions as the
rate of death continues to increase the
mayor of one city says the true numbers
are even higher with many untested
people dying at home
the lockdowns are now even stricter with
bans on exercise outside people are only
allowed out for emergencies or to get
food in Spain the crisis is just a few
days behind Italy this conference center
is being set up to treat the rapidly
rising number of cases get food or to
the pharmacy that kind of necessary
supplies Albertans a curling is in
Prague and fears he'll be stuck if his
flight home gets cancelled take 20,000
Czech crown I'm not having a mask on so
it's pretty intense that's $1,000 in
neighboring Slovakia this is how the new
government was sworn into office
Saturday in France the lockdown is not
as stringent as Italy but much of Paris
is effectively closed for business
Putin the country's Health Minister
issued an open invitation for citizens
to play their part by donating stored
face masks to health workers Germany too
is preparing for the worst and central
London is almost empty of tourists
but many Londoners are still going about
their business as normal
despite the new measures in effect
British bars may be closed but it is far
from a full lockdown here but looking at
what's happened in the rest of Europe
the UK could be headed that way too with
a strategy you turned from the British
government this week the messaging on
social distancing is not hitting home
with everyone the long term or indeed
short term consequences of that may soon
become apparent Redman Shannon Global
News London
still ahead the loss of a legend Kenny
Rogers dead at 81
you are watching global national
[Music]
country music legend Kenny Rogers has
died his career spanned nearly six
decades and he topped the country and
pop music charts twenty four times he
grew up in the Houston projects and
credits music for changing his life he
first found success in the 1960s with
his band the first edition but it was
when he went solo in 1977 that he became
a superstar with his breakthrough song
Lucille some of Rogers biggest hits came
in collaboration with longtime friends
like Lionel Richie and Dolly Parton
I love Kenny with all my heart my
heart's broken and a big old chunk of it
has gone with him today Parton was at
Rogers farewell concert in 2017 he ended
his music career citing health
challenges today his family said he died
peacefully at home from natural causes
[Music]
can't forget that song the rogers family
is planning a small private service
because of the corona virus pandemic
they say they will celebrate his life
publicly with his friends and fans at a
later date up next finding harmony in
quarantine the perfect pitch to help
flatten the curve for those of you
singing the self-isolation blues you're
probably looking for ways to tune into
communities as reggie Cecchini explains
sharing music has become a major key to
connecting with others responsibly once
vibrant communities now sit quiet
patiently awaiting the return of ambient
sounds and as concerns over kovat 19
crescendo music is being used as a form
of therapy some of the biggest names in
the recording industry are turning
self-isolation day6 into something
intimate and interactive imagine there's
no homes now feel more like cages so
many musicians are using the only means
some people have to be social as a way
to engage them in conversation kind of
the kind of and distract them from chaos
it is really good to notice that there
are some science of forms you know
common humanity and hope that are
showing up amid this crisis these
socially distant performances for a few
minutes
allow everyone tuning in a chance to
calm and sing along but it's not just
small screen performances getting big
reviews kids playing for an elderly
neighbor keeping her distance it feels
scary I'm staying at home a quartet
replacing the bandstand with a basement
they're doing something that's a value
to society the window has become a way
to let the air in and the talent out
while balconies act as a one-person
stage that turn into a chorus of
quarantine townspeople I hope you feel
comfortable with how far apart we are
even in the most difficult times music
acts as a universal medicine and helps
bring the world a little bit closer no
matter how isolated we feel and how far
apart we are
Reggie Cecchini global news and that is
global national for this Saturday I'm
Robin Gill
we're going to keep bringing you the
latest kovin 19 news as it happens but
we also want to offer some lighter
moments during this new reality here's a
little Christmas spirit in spring the
trend lights for life is taking off
across Canada as people decorate their
homes to lift hopes thank you for
watching have a great night
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]